السيد عدنان غيث محافظ القدس استاذ عدنان
انت محافظ القدس ما الذي يمكن ان تقوله
تعليقا على ما حدث قبل قليل
يعني مساء الخير لكم اخي الكريم
يعني ماذا يمكن انه ما يجري الان هو عدوان
بكل ما تعني الكلمه من معنى هذا عدوان
بربري همجي استعماري يطال كل ما يتحرك على
هذه الارض المباركه وهذه يعني ليست اللحظه
المخططات الراميه الى الانقضاض على المسجد
الاقصى المبارك واليوم يريدون تقسيمه
مكنيا لانه تقسيمه زمنيا حقيقه هذا
الاحتلال الصفاء السنوات السابقه ان يثبت
هذا الامر بالنسبه للمشاهدين بالنسبه
لمشاهدينا غير الفلسطينيين او غير
المغناطيسيين الذين يسمعون هذا الكلام
بشكل متكرر التقسيم الزماني والمكاني ما
المقصود به
ان يحول المسجد الاقصى المبارك المجره في
الحرم الشريف ويريد ان يعني
يثبت له موطئ قدم في هذا المكان هذا
المكان المقدس وان اقول لك بان نواياها في
المسجد الاقصى المبارك تذهب على ابعد من
ذلك ما يتم من دعوات لغات المتطرفين
المنظمات المتطرفه بين الفينه والاخرى
تؤكد العقليه الهمجيه التي تستهدف هذا
المكان المقدس هذا يعني يجب ان يعيد كل
عربي وكل مسلم انه كرامه لعربي ومسلم اذا
ما تم الانتظار والانتباحه هذا المكان
المقدس هذا اولى القبلتين وثالث الحرمين
الشريفين هذا سيدنا محمد عليه الصلاه
والسلام حباب الله كفلسطينيون ومقدسيون
بان نكون راس حربه وخط دفاع اولا ندافع
بصدورنا العاريه عن يعني اقدس موقع تؤمن
على هذه الامانه ولكن ندافع نيابه عن
الامه العربيه والاسلاميه عن شرف اسمح لي
سيدي عدنان وانهي لهذه الصور من ام الفحم
ايضا طبعا مظاهرات لم تكن في ام الفحم فقط
كما كما قال لنا الصحفيون
كانت في حيفا وفي الناصره وفي اماكن اخرى
ولكن هذه الصور على كل حال تاتينا من ام
الفحم والاذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي تقولون
ان المتظاهرين يحرقون الاطارات ويرزقون
الحجاره عقب احداث الاقصى اعود اليك سيدي
عدنان غيث يعني يبدو وكانه في القدس
الفلسطينيون يتعاملون بنوع من الرويه
والتريث في وكان رد الفعل محسوب
في تقديم الغالي والنفيس من اجل القضيه
ومن اجل المقدساته وعلى راس المسجد الاقصى
المبارك ولا طالما صدر اهلنا وشعبنا
الفلسطيني وخاصه ان في القدس نماذج مشرفه
في حمايه هذا المكان المقدس والحفاظ على
عروبه
وطالما نقول وما زلنا نقول ونؤكد باننا
سنعمل بكل امكانياتنا من اجل ان يبقى هذا
المكان مكان الخلف والمسلمين وحده انا
اقول بانه ما يجري اخي الكريم لم يعني
يقدر هذا الاحتلال على ما يقدم عليه من
عدوان غاشم لولا اخي الكريم انه يعي تماما
هذا الاحتلال بانه لا يوجد هناك من يحاسبه
على جراء وما يجد هناك من يحاسبه على
مجازر يرتكبها بحق مقدساتنا وبحق شعبنا
الفلسطيني هذا الاحتلال طالما يعني بانه
يعني هناك من يعني يدين ويشعر بالقلق تجاه
ما يجري بحق شعبه فلسطيني سيستمر
لهذه المجال
مصالح ومهدده مع العالم وانه هناك من
سيحاسبه
هذا الاحزاب في عدوانه وفي سلفه وفي
اجرامه وبحق شعبنا الفلسطيني شعبنا
الفلسطيني 14 مليون فلسطيني على وجه
البسيطه ليسوا باريس سبيل وليسوا مارقين
على هذه
واصحاب عرس واصحاب تاريخ 75 وهذا الاحتيال
يبحث عن يعني
حقيته في هذا المكان ولم يجد شيئا اخي
الكريم لانه هذه الارضيه ارض عربيه
اسلاميه وهذا المكان هو الذي يجب يعني
واوصى الرسول عليه الصلاه والسلام بشد
الرحال اليه نحن في شهر مبارك في شهر فضيل
يحتفي كل المسلمين في العالم في هذا الشهر
المبارك في اماكن عبادتهم في عبادتهم
وشعبنا الفلسطيني يحتفي في المسجد الاقصى
المبارك ويقيم عبادته باقي المسلمين
وجعب هذا الاحتلال الا ان ينغز ويرتكب
ثراء بحق شعبنا فلسطيني هو اليوم يعتدي بل
يكسر العظام اخي الكريم يعتدي على النساء
وعلى الشيوخ وعلى الاطفال وعلى الشبان
ويعتقل بالمئات ويبعد بالمئات من اجل
تفريغ المكان الى هناك المتطرفين لاقتحام
المسجد الاقصى المبارك بل تناولت هذه
الدعوات بانه يقدمون
الى المسجد الاقصى المتوقع الان يعني هذه
ما حدث كان افراغ للمسجد الاقصى من كافه
المصلين هل هل سيمنع المسلمون من صلاه
التراويح مثلا او ان يصلوا الصلوات الخمس
غدا ما الذي يمكن ان نتوقعه بعد هذه
الخطوه التي لم لم يكن لها يعني لم يكن
هناك اي استفزاز اي احتكاك اي شيء هكذا
فجاه بداوا بالهجوم على المصلين ما الذي
يمكن ان يلي ذلك
يا اخي الكريم اي استفزاز عندما اذهب انا
كمسلم كفلسطيني الى مسجد الاقصى المبارك
لاقيم عبادتي استفزيت مين في هذا الحديث
انا لم استفز احدا من يستفز ومن يقتحم
المكان من المقدس صلاه التراويح انتهت كيف
انتهت صلاه التراويح قام باقتحام المسجد
الاقصى
الى هذه الصور وهي من مخيم شعفاط قبل قليل
طبعا هناك غضب والاوضاع
متوتره نعم سؤالي لك كان ما دام انهم
قاموا بهذه الطريقه دون اي نوع من
الاحتكاك اصلا وبلا اي سبب على اي مبرر
فما الذي يمكن ان نتوقعه بعد هذه الخطوه
وبالتالي هم يريدون ان يفرغوا المسجد
الاقصى المبارك من مؤمن به لتوفروا هذه
الاقتحامات الان هم اعتدوا
على الاقصى المباراه وسيحددوا في صلاه
الفجر اعمار محدده للدخول الى المسجد
المباراه وعندما ياتي ساعات الصباح في
الساعه السابعه وهو الساعه يعني التي
اعتاد ان يقتحم فيها غلاف المتطرفين
المسجد الاقصى المبارك سيقومون بالاعتداء
على المصلين كما حدث اليوم من اجل يعني
حمايه ومن اجل تسهيل يعني اقتحامات الى
المسجد الاقصى المبارك على اعتبار انه غدا
هو يوم الخميس وبالتالي هذا الاحتلال هذا
الامر بشكل دائم هذا الاعتداء وهذا
الاجرام وهذا الانتهاك لحرمه المقدس
اسلاميه ومسيحيه وعضلات المسجد الاقصى
المبارك هذا ليس وليد اللحظه ولكن ما يجري
اليوم هو عدوان غاشم هم اقتحموا بل ليس
فقط يعني اعتدوا على المصلين وكسروا
العظام اعتدوا على على
هذا الاحتلال عن جرائه وحاكم مجرميه
وقادته على ما يرتكبوه بحق يعني ابناءنا
وبحق شعبنا الفلسطيني ما يمارسه اليوم
بدعوات الجمعيات الاستيطانيه وبغطاء كامل
من هذه الحكومه المت بغطاء شكرا للامن
الداخلي وبغطاء من الحكومه بشكل كامل في
اطار هذا العدوان الغاشم وهذه المجازر
التي ترتكب من عدوان وتكفير عظام وتكفير
مساجد ويعني اقتحامات وابعادات واعتقالات
في حق ابناء شعبنا في العاصمه